[Music]
try to try to knock me down we could
wring your body
keep trying to talk me down
yes so the union lets it go by but has
an adhesion you're not cutting it down
right I let it go by and then I iced it
on the top you see that the young man is
the inverse spiral so it's a pole Q
projection in the center
so ie in your head here hope you absorb
and project you see that
so without the IP this line the copula
goes that way right you see what I'm
gonna do the hiking goes this way
but I I'm not doing that to him
I'm not turning him to make him go that
way
I lead his spine and projec see that the
same inward position don't do to young
hands
he'll and in here he'll boom and to chat
don't hop Cesare and make it external
just like don't cut it down you're gonna
hear I did you're going to keep it here
keep it here and keep it here and keep
it here and keep it here
I don't need to get all this way that's
going to jack up this you see this has
to hit Sheila
then you'll feel that release bonds just
like yesterday we were going to the
mouth then I don't hold him down I just
keep my posture and he's trying to push
me up you'll hold him down you're going
to be tilted he's go I'm not trying to
cut him down I'm just keeping my own
self
keep going you see relax but just okay
okay he does the same thing so when he
comes in this cocky projection is not
from me throwing him it's from me
this happen loading descent so the
energy that you're using you're using
your own active energy this technique
has this yield bomb and so there's a
target boom you can't call same time
same time is no you didn't do okay all
right we should calculate past you know
hey boy over here
don't lean your spine but don't bring
your hot spot you know Hans on here you
see that he pushes but the positioning
of my hands has nothing to do with this
drill okay so don't go must be vertical
you must have centerline it's not
vertical it's here and he's go my hands
are connected to my Center and he can't
lift my Center
you see it sounds over there
it sounds finished that IKEA TV over
here and that's where we all stand no no
no no you're trying to get a skeletal
alignment and this time here just
relaxed it's not that okay it's just
here you can put it here he's not gonna
live that's the that's why it's called
cookie wall it's a drill for developing
the stability or the integrity of
organization okay
he's pushing on trying to disorganize
you okay but the organization we're
talking about is not skeletal alignment
once he gets that I okay that's where it
was right
that because my turning point is you
don't do that
cut the arm and now this thing is in the
way there's no really good space there
push don't let me in see you guys see
that
so we be here now I can turn inside of
it
this is not it's not going to be in my
way you see that it's not over here when
you can stop the turn
never caught here that would wear it
finished will rewind and I go inside the
arm you see that so watch maybe you
started that way looks pretty good then
you start coming back to turn and now
you're caught there stop me keep it
going it stays yet okay it never
contests with him if you drive in with
your stomach muscles so you get some
extra you got it and I get some extra
okay okay okay so I'm not gonna do that
I'm doing this
they don't want any don't want
yeah
immediately angle counseling you see how
the fights changed and not have my
magazine do you see that
[Music]
see this Holly thinks giving you
problems you try to increase space
permit but there is no more space you
just brought them up this time
is this way first you see that with my
body going now I have the top bottom
rotate around then indeed this time the
angle cancellation boom his shoulder
comes in front of this shoulder boom you
see not
shoulder shoulder this shoulder here so
I mean this is only site
under this hand is your upward spiral
just small so our spiral just small our
first five
inward spiral inwards so we're gonna
leave the Ike and the cook you off and
you're just gonna understand the anatomy
so first move one clear good into the
zone the sanctuary you're gonna make
with this inward spiral do you see that
then go round on by inspired then two
with that shoulder in front
yeah yeah okay Louis anatomical
positioning okay but I have to do the
energetic so this time is going here so
he hits that man do you understand
but as he hits this hand on that
shoulder it has to be in the way of the
other shoulder you see that and this
yield has to happen so that it goes and
keeps going with the IQ agent so that
when this projection line home it'll
cause his hip to go over you'll have a
Kazushi planner then this arm will be in
the in space or will create it in space
that you can eat me into it's when you
start it up you just brought him
up I didn't he just mount you so cool
I'm there in push my arms were born
because they were in in space so I don't
have to be here when he can't get very
strong and push on me whoo okay Oh what
you get when you get higher still it
doesn't matter what your arms are doing
they could be totally goofy your body
can be totally give me push he's never
gonna get it okay you can go push push
okay but at the beginning
here okay so do the hand moves right so
you have a chance
oh okay let's go finish